Si fuera una niña y quisiera representar 1
de algo, quizás sólo escribiría uno como una
vara o un palito; si quisiera representar 2
escribiría dos palitos, así: uno más uno; 3,
tres palitos, uno junto al otro. Podemos ver en
lo que escribí que lo que tengo es solamente uno
más uno más uno, tres. A esta forma de escribir
se le llama aditiva, sólo sumo lo que está aquí
de manera individual porque sé que esta forma que
parece una I representa a 1, entonces sumo III,
tres íes, y esto es 3. Los números romanos
siguen esta idea de la representación aditiva
de los números. Ahora voy a buscar el 1, y ¿qué
es 1? Voy aquí a mi tabla: 1 lo escribo como I,
sólo I, y luego para 2 necesito dos unos y los
voy a escribir uno al lado del otro, así: II;
entonces 3 será, exacto, III; 4 entonces va a
ser IIII. En realidad no, parecería correcto
hacer esto tres íes para 3, cuatro íes para 4,
pero resulta que esto no es así, ya no, el 4
es complicado, lo voy a dejar así y hablaremos de
él más tarde. Después de esto, ¿cómo haríamos el
5? Quizá podría poner IIIII, ¿pero qué sucede?,
se vuelve difícil de leer. Los romanos asignaron
una nueva letra para 5, así que pondré el 5 así
porque es más sencillo. Ahora, ¿qué debo hacer
con el 6? El 6 es bastante interesante porque
¿cómo lo escribo? Cuando veo el 6, miro esta
tabla y me pregunto ¿qué es lo más grande que hay
que sea menor que 6? El 6 está entre el 5 y el 10,
así que ahora sé que puedo escribir 6 como 5 más
algo, entonces primero escribo el 5 que es V,
y me pregunto qué le falta, le falta un 1 y
ya sé cómo escribir 1, así que lo escribo;
y pasa lo mismo para 7: 5 + 2; 8 es 5 + 3; para
el 9 voy a poner de nuevo un signo de interrogación,
porque se escribe de forma distinta, no escribimos
VIIII, con las cuatro íes sería muy largo,
entonces pondré el signo de interrogación, veremos
después cómo se escriben estos; y para 10 vuelvo
a mi tabla, ya tenemos una letra para 10, y es la
que voy a usar. Ahora veamos un ejemplo: si tengo
23 y quiero escribirlo con números romanos, ¿en
qué debo pensar? Muy bien, 23 es mayor que 10 y
menor que 50, así que lo escribiré como la suma de
dieces y veré qué pasa. ¿Cuántos dieces hay aquí?
Puedo ver que hay dos dieces, así que escribiré
dos dieces, dos dieces, X X. ¿Es suficiente? No,
lo que tengo es 20 y lo que quiero es 23.
Imagina este 23 como 20 + 3 y este es 20,
ya está escrito aquí, así que faltan estos tres,
y lo pienso como si fuera un número nuevo: 3 está
entre 1 y 5, pero ya sé cómo se escribe 3, voy a
escribirlo: uno, dos, tres, así que XXIII es 23. Y
si me hubieran dado este número, ¿cómo lo leería?
Empezaría diciendo X es 10 y X es 10, entonces
10 + 10 es 20, I es 1, III es 3; esto es 20, esto
es 3, y 20 más 3 es 23. Es el mismo proceso que
usamos antes pero a la inversa. Y podemos darnos
cuenta de que en estos casos escribimos primero
el número más grande y luego los más pequeños, por
eso XX está antes de III. Por aquí podemos ver que
V está antes de I, entonces, mientras escribamos
los números comunes, usaremos este formato:
primero el mayor y luego los menores. Pero
estos casos dijimos que eran complicados,
4 y 9. ¿Cómo escribimos 4 y 9? No vamos a pensar
que 4 son cuatro unos -IIII-, aunque de hecho en
el tiempo de los romanos la gente solía escribirlo
así, pero dejaron de hacerlo porque ocupaba mucho
espacio y en los documentos importantes, donde no
había tanto espacio, querían una forma más corta
de escribir 4. ¿Pero cuál es la forma más corta de
escribir 4? Ellos pensaron en cuatro como 1 menos
que 5, entonces puedo poner una I y luego escribir
una V, esta es la primera vez que vemos que un
número más pequeño se escribe antes que un número
mayor. Pensaban que cada vez que esto sucediera
no se leyera como 1 + 5 = 6, sino como 5 - 1 que es
4; lo mismo sucede con el 9: pensemos que es 10 - 1,
o 1 menos que 10. De esta forma tenemos IV para
4 e IX para 9, y esto se conoce como notación
sustractiva. El nombre no es tan importante,
pero sirve para comprender que cuando escribimos
de esta forma realmente estamos haciendo una
sustracción, una resta: 5 - 1 y 10 - 1. Ahora,
lo más importante que hay que saber sobre
esta notación sustractiva es que es muy rara,
pasa muy pocas veces. Voy a escribir aquí 4 y 9,
4 es IV y 9 es IX, entonces ¿cuándo se utiliza la
notación sustractiva? Como dije antes, se usa muy
rara vez, de hecho los únicos casos especiales son
4 y 9. ¿No se usa en ningún otro caso? Sí, pero
sólo para múltiplos de 4 y 9: 4 y 9, 40 y 90, 400
y 900, sólo para estos números usamos la notación
sustractiva. Olvidémonos por ahora de 400 y 900,
son números muy grandes, tomemos solamente 4,
9, 40 y 90. Ya sabemos cómo escribir 4, IV, 9 lo
escribimos como IX, ahora ¿cómo escribimos 40? En
lugar de pensar en cuatro dieces y escribir XXXX,
lo que haremos es ver el 40 como 50 - 10 o 10
menos que 50. ¿Después qué hacemos? 50 es L, así
que escribo XL. Piensa un momento cómo escribirías
90 y luego lo haremos juntos. Entonces, ¿cómo
harías 90? Buscamos primero 100 aquí y luego
le restamos 10, 10 menos que 100 esto es 90.